I'm going to be opening the subcommittee
hearing on Senate Bill 58 and then going
into recess for about five minutes we're
waiting for one Committee Member to join
us
thank you
we are now at a recess
is there anyone who'd like to speak on
this bill
out of recess
here yeah
let me check
it nobody
good morning Paul I'm in the hand
Hospital Association
um I guess I we want to just kind of
hear the conversation if you have any
questions we're here to answer your
questions that you heard our testimony
last week we
obviously I'm very supportive of the
concept
um outlined in in Senate Bill 58 as far
as how we get to yes I think is where
we're why we're here today and we
certainly want um to ensure that all
stakeholders are heard but the goal is
to
ensure that our health care workers are
protected
um in these situations that have been
described so I'm happy to answer any
questions and John Patty from CMC is
also here who's in charge of security
um so can talk from a security officer
perspective but we're just really
hopeful that we can pass something that
can can protect our health care workers
thank you
anyone have any questions from the
committee
no thank you
I know you had some ideas on how to get
here get there
I believe your first name is John
I do have a few questions for you if you
wouldn't mind stepping up sir
good morning
so is okay got it it's good
so one of the questions I have is you're
from CMC yes sir how do your security
Personnel handle uh excuse let me read
back that up is your security Personnel
in-house yes and they are not licensed
through the state they're under the
exemption for security guard licensing
correct okay
what kind of training do your
individuals receive or do you mandate
so we we go through a 120 hour field
training so you know new employee will
get 40 hours on each shift to go through
you know our policies and procedures
learning the hospital
typical training you would get for any
organization but then we have
um use of force training you know we do
carry equipment with us we carry
handcuffs
pepper gel and tasers
so we go through a required training on
that and then we have annual
recertification for that training as
well
so you maintain certifications for any
use of forest techniques that you use
yes sir thank you
anyone have any other questions
yes
representative Muse
when there is an incident in uh in an
emergency room an incident like the the
ones we've been talking about in in this
hearing and others
um
what are uh security Personnel
instructed to do and and what are the
medical personnel themselves instructed
to do currently
so you know instructed so our first
um
our our main goal obviously is that
safety of the staff and the patient
right so when there are instances when
there are physical assaults we're asked
to
I would I would say
um
maintain the order in the room right
because there are other
not only are we concerned with the
um
patient involved and the clinical staff
member involved but there's other people
in that area as well so we have to make
sure that the area is safe for them
right so you know we do have
statutory protection to maintain that
safety and decorum in there which is
something that we had sought a few years
ago and
was passed so we have that protection
but clearly our role as Security is to
maintain the safety of everybody
involved so if that includes you know
physical Force non-deadly physical Force
then that's what we would use
follow-up
and the medical personnel themselves uh
so I know this isn't something that uh
that that people like to think about but
from what I understand this is a fairly
common occurrence in emergency rooms and
hospitals these days
um
how do you instruct a doctor or a nurse
who is
either concerned about being assaulted
or
um or who
may find themselves in the position of
being assaulted by a patient
sure so we would like to take a
proactive approach you know if we if we
I say we if a clinician suspects that
there may be
a concern with the behavior of a patient
they will ask for us to stand by but as
you know anybody knows just from
you know
common sense and living right these
situations are volatile and can you know
erupt at any moment so we would always
ask for them to take a proactive
approach and ask for us to be there
however in in the event when something
happens and it's not expected we have
certain
policies and procedures that the medical
staff would follow to call for our
assistance
and what specifically are they
instructed to do
so so we have um you know overhead
codes that can be called
um we also carry
um mobile safety pendants right so that
similar to
um you know in the old commercial I've
fallen I can't get up type of thing
right so
um Fury call
I don't know probably eight years ago no
probably nine or ten years ago now the
um nurse at the Elliott Hospital who was
severely injured
um
by a mental health patient
um he was trying to get to a static
alarm on the wall and couldn't get it so
when I got the CMC we implemented this
mobile pendant so that they can carry it
with them so if there's an event they
can press this and it alerts
um Communications to what the problem is
and where we're made aware of it to
respond there so you know they they have
they have options that they can take
um you know again proactive is the best
approach approach however when that
can't happen we do have policies in
place for that
um so I'm assuming that since you have
the the mobile pendants uh security
officer is not always present in areas
like the emergency room
so we try to be you know depending on
Staffing levels and calls for service
throughout the organization
um you know we do
you know roughly 40 000 calls you know
for security every year so you know
we're busy based on you know our FTE so
we're not always available there um it
is one of our
assigned posts from
noon to midnight
um you know other organizations have
different Staffing structures that they
use
but we also are responsible for
safety in our Annex which is where the
iea patients are held so where whenever
we have an IA patient our resources are
directed to that
area
you're welcome hey trying to ask whether
they're the staff is instructed to
evacuate or fight is that what you're
trying to get at
not necessarily I'm trying to figure out
where we're going I think I think part
of it is we've all sort of seen stuff
like this on TV but how things play out
on TV isn't necessarily the way that
they they play out in reality so I think
um what I'm what I was just trying to
understand was just I'm just trying to
have a better mental picture of
um of
how security personnel and medical staff
are are supposed to react when something
like this goes down
and uh
and and I think that'll help us inform
what we do here today
yeah sure
um
you know so if you picture you know an
emergency room whatever size we have 26
rooms right so it's not possible
possible for us to be you know in every
spot at every time
um you know with these situations going
on
at different moments you know we could
be dealing with it with an issue you
know one side of the Ed you know when
something happens on the other side
right so you know we're not no Ed is big
enough where you can't hear you know
what's going on so there could be a yell
you know you know some security right so
you know that message gets passed down
right so it's just that we're not always
available at that moment to be in the
room with the clinician
sure one more question
um do you typically have security
cameras in areas like that where you can
go back afterwards and track through uh
what happened or is there a patient uh
confidentiality and issue that we need
to be aware of there as well yeah so
it's a that's a delicate balance yes of
course we can't have cameras in the in
the patient care setting so it depends
on where in the hospital this may happen
yeah
you're welcome
representative Manion thank you and
thank you for taking my question uh you
mentioned earlier that there was an RSA
change or a bill that passed a few years
ago that allows hospital security uh
justification for physical force and
detaining people
how would this build so your that's
already authorized this bill would
specifically allow non-security
Personnel doctors uh nurses and whatnot
those same protections as am I
understanding that correctly is that how
you see this bill
so that language you know in this
particular bill I think was added
because it seemed to match the language
in the statute that it's trying to be
placed under right
um
we don't need that
level of
Authority right you know so we we have
the authority to detain and maintain
safety and decorum anyway so that
language isn't in there and I think it's
kind of
taking away from the intention of this
bill right the intention is to give the
police
more clarity to come in and make that
warrantless arrest when the situation
presents itself you know my opinion on
this you know that language was again
included in this bill only to match the
language you know for a merchant to
detain a shoplifter
um yeah I don't think that that's
necessarily required under this bill
so and then there's a separate uh
Amendment here that specifically
in a different RSA that will place that
Authority for a law enforcement office
to make an arrest without a warrant
based on your detention I guess my
question would be if a healthcare
providers in a scenario where they don't
have security a smaller hospital or
doctor's office or something else
do you think it would still be valuable
to allow
at least a justification for any health
care provider to use some physical Force
to change somebody
for those smaller agencies that don't
have security right I guess maybe that's
what I'm thinking this is weird towards
I think you know everybody as you know
everybody has the right to defend
themselves and that you know if that
includes having to detain somebody until
the threat is over you know they're
already protected by that
um you know CMS
um
has specific guidelines about
detention and releasing a you know
releasing
um
removing a restraint you know as soon as
possible right so you know those are the
guidelines with you know that we follow
as well so as soon as the threat is over
that detention you know can be released
um so I'm not certain that there's any
clinician who would really
be interested in you know detaining
somebody of course it's unless for their
own protection
um you know but in the in the event of a
hospital that has contract security
you know that's a different matter I
would think however they're still
protected under that other statute
thank you you're welcome
any other questions
um in a situation where you where you
have an incident and you've called the
police what is the procedure now does a
security person
detain the person if they're trying to
if they're trying to get away
how does it work now
so you know if they're if they're trying
to get away right the the intention of
this bill for me right is to
provide the victim of the assault
which you know a clinician here right
um
some type of protection so if there's an
assault and the patient runs out of the
hospital right you know then that threat
to us to the clinician is gone right
that's
you know
from from a security perspective that's
okay you know from a clinician or a
clinical perspective probably not right
so
um so that's a different matter so if we
take an assault that happens and we call
the police and they come in and you know
there's evidence of an assault they do
their investigation and you know this um
probable cause to believe that this
crime has been committed well it's a
misdemeanor level offense and you know
except for a few limited exceptions
you know they may they're not going to
make that arrest so again just for a
little bit of background
um not to bore you guys
um you know
in in my years of law enforcement I
can't ever remember making an arrest
based on this um exception you know
where the
um you predict future Behavior you know
it kind of the municipalities I worked
for kind of saw that as a um
a risk right you know uh and so
um although it's on it's on the books
um wasn't always used for that reason so
you know this is just some clarity to
the police that they can arrest in this
particular situation
um so
right now if we call the police and they
find that there's evidence of this
misdemeanor level assault they'll take
the information and if the victim wants
to proceed with the matter they'll um
request a warrant an arrest warrant
you know I've heard testimony that you
know would be okay just to you know take
that approach
and it I would say depending on the size
of the community
um you know the speed with which you can
get a warrant differs greatly
um
you know in my experience at Manchester
police you know it could take over a
week to get a warrant sometimes you know
based on this level of offense you know
if you picture you know an officer going
in does the report maybe goes on days
off comes back you know submits his
request to the judge for Warrant has to
be sent over to the court reviewed it
could be a little bit of time that goes
by it's not always the case where you
can go to a small smaller Community you
know go to a JP and have that warrant
signed right right away
doesn't always work that way
any other questions
I have one for follow-up
how many felony level offenses have you
seen occur for assaults while you're
tenure at the CMC
I'd say probably a half dozen
they have been arrested without a
warrant
they they can be arrested without a
warrant so you know again the victim
still has the right to decide if they
want to pursue so you know the felony
level
um you know with the serious bottle
injury could be you know uh you know
they don't know they may have a broken
nose at the time right so you know it
takes a little while and when they when
the medical records are done you know
that that moment has passed yeah so
there are those
um I've been you know as a police
officer I saw some felony level so again
that the felony level is
is covered where you know we're good
with that the majority of the assaults
that we're dealing with are the
misdemeanor level offenses which still
create a lot of anxiety
thank you you're welcome
any follow-up
thank you no thank you very much I
appreciate the attention this is getting
anyone else offer to testimony please
step up and identify yourself
good morning I'm Karen Rosenberg I'm the
policy director at the disability rights
Center thank you so much for your time
this morning
Our concern is that there is a problem
with Workforce safety
but this is not the solution that
matches that problem and appropriately
addresses it
and the the reason I say this is that
when the
we for well
I think the situations we're talking
about for the most part involve people
who experience mental illness who are
transported to a hospital on an
involuntary emergency admission they are
in great psychological distress
and
I don't think that this committee wants
to criminalize that behavior at the same
time we don't want our health care
Workforce
put in danger
so I think what you know there was a
study committee about this issue and one
of the primary recommendations was that
in all instances wherever possible that
de-escalation techniques be practiced so
these warrantless arrests that we're
talking about would occur after the
healthcare workers already sustained an
injury
so instead of focusing there if we look
to what's what's the root of the problem
we have a very it's a very distressed
population
individuals who are experiencing
significant mental illness
you know very disoriented maybe you know
hearing voices maybe really afraid
and their emotions everything is
escalated so
but and but they need treatment
so
if they are no longer presenting a
danger I don't know why we would want to
if you know they've flailed to try to
avoid a restraint for example
knocked a health care worker why would
we want to criminalize that divert them
to the court system instead of trying to
figure out a way to help them regain
some composure and be able to get
treatment that healthcare worker already
was hit instead I think we need to work
on providing the resources that
healthcare workers require the training
to be able to know how to de-escalate
when to back off support they might need
consulting services or support from
Psychiatric or psychological
professionals they may need some
additional training
you know all manner of things to address
the problem here which is that we've got
a really
volatile some volatile people who are
experiencing mental illness
who you know if if they aren't treated
appropriately could end up
you know in some unprivileged physical
contact that's what we're talking about
here and I and we don't want our
healthcare workers subjected to that
we don't want our patients to have to be
diverted to the criminal justice system
unnecessarily
well
representative wheeler thank you Mr
chairman
um the from your perspective would you
say that the a better solution to this
would be mental health institutions
where we could place people who may have
uh
a need for a care but can't necessarily
be in the care of someone who doesn't
understand or have the right training to
I think there's like multiple things
that need to happen
in in the ideal world I DRC my
organization is not a real proponent of
over institutionalization I think part
of the issue is that we don't have
adequate an adequate array of robust
community-based services so that we can
discharge people from our psychiatric
hospital or from transitional housing
into the community so and so that's
created this backdoor problem right
we're not getting people out when
they're ready to leave the Department of
Health and Human Services has publicly
stated on multiple occasions that from
New Hampshire hospital has that they
have about 60 people on any given day
who are ready for discharge and not
appropriate for that setting but they
don't have an appropriate place to
discharge them too and we do have some
transitional housing but it's become
sort of a transition to Nowhere right
because we don't have the place the step
down for the people in transitional
housing to make room for the people who
are ready to leave the hospital so that
that's one aspect of the problem
and you know fundamentally we need to be
able to treat people in the community
and provide services before someone gets
to a crisis level of need so that's
another way to address the issue besides
beds and housing and residential
supports would be to have a more robust
Community Based Services System so those
are things that need to happen I
understand that you know we don't get to
wave a magic wand and make that happen
tomorrow too bad
but in the meantime we know that we have
this issue that is being worked on in
various ways
um
so what can we do for the people who we
know are going to ultimately or you know
for a while anyway
be in Psycho psychiatric distress
because we know they exist they're going
to end up in our hospitals and they're
not going to be in the right Hospital
and they're going to be in distress at
the same time understanding that we
don't want our health care workers put
at risk and and this is you know where I
think we need to consider
whether a warrantless arrest expanding
our warrantless arrest statute is
actually going to address that problem I
don't see it addressing that problem I
see it removing some important civil
rights that people have
um to not have a warrantless arrest
except in certain circumstances where
there's you know exigency they're you
know gonna flee what like our current
law says if they're going to be
destroying evidence fleeing from the
scene which is unlikely at a hospital or
as was in the bill as introduced
um where it was this concept was
slightly expanded where they are
actually interfering with the delivery
of medically necessary services and
they're disrupting the hospital so that
that's why the bill wasn't the language
was developed the way it was to
recognize that maybe there would be this
time when someone despite all efforts is
continuing to really disrupt the ability
of the facilities to do their job and
treat people and that's why the parties
that came together including my office
reluctantly thought you know that that
may make sense as an expansion but to
expand our warrantless arrest law for
misdemeanors including times when the
person is no longer they're not they're
not leaving we know who they are they're
not stealing the hospital stuff
like a merchant situation
and and they're no longer interfering
with the operations of the hospital why
would we want to expand our law in such
a way to divert those folks to the
criminal justice system without a
warrant
remembering they can be arrested
it's just you know the warrant process
would have to be followed
representative
so I have like five questions in my head
for you
so
and I'm going to make a little statement
first but
so I'm going to empty I go into
hospitals all the time
and because of the problems that you
were talking about
I'm pretty sure our Hospital staff has
been trained to deal with the mental
health issues right because
they're parked in there for days at a
time they're dealing with them they've
learned how to deal with them they
understand that
and I know as a mental health as a
provider of emergency care
a mental health person is flailing about
and hits me because they have no idea
what they're doing I chalk that up to I
forgot to duck right and I'm not going
to file a charge on them
the person I'm gonna file a charge on
that I want arrested and removed
is the drunk
who
stood up knelt up on the stretcher
cornered the nurse and grabbed her
multiple times until somebody came over
and stopped him
and then when the security came
he was ready to go again
that guy needs to be removed right that
guy needs to be arrested and gone so
those are the patients that we're
looking at right are the ones that are
just going to continue
and of course as soon as the police
officer walks in they go
I'm just sitting here they're making
this all up
I've seen it I've witnessed it
that's where this bill comes into effect
because you know as soon as the cop
leaves
he's back on
I've seen that too
so this is what I see is the problem
that everybody seems to be missing and
focusing on the mental health patient
who is not going to be the one that we
want arrested because we understand it
going through a psychotic issue
so
I think you all are missing the point
can I address that I think I hear what
you're saying in that situation that you
describe where the person is they're
drunk they're unruly they're continuing
to be threatening
I think that that person
could end up if in terms of how the bill
was introduced it it said through actual
or threatened violence interferes in the
provision of medically necessary Health
Care Services I think that that
situation would be covered it sounds
like that person is only you know is
like having doing this doing this doing
this person police officer walks out of
the room doing it doing it doing it you
have reason to believe that's what's
happening here I think that could get
the police officer what they need to do
a warrantless arrest without amending
this statute and the risk is that
the situation you're talking about you
sound like a really
well-informed well-trained EMT who
understands mental health issues and
you know the what you said about being
able like knowing when to duck not
everyone
is is this trained or sensitive or maybe
wouldn't be interested in pressing
charges as you and we're legislating for
all situations
um if everyone could be like you it
might not be as big a problem right but
we but we know that that's not the case
I'd rather err on the side of the
healthcare worker
I hear what you're saying people have to
go to work stay there
and get their ass beat
on a regular basis and there's nothing
they can do about it that's not good
with me I I hear you I'm just not sure
at at this point like let's play this
out if this were to happen the
healthcare workers already sustained an
injury
and if he stays he's going to get
another one
well the person could be charged
the person if the person presents an
ongoing
danger then they could be arrested
without a warrant
um
and I I really do think like we we need
probably to look at this with a broader
brush we have to let this commission and
I don't understand why the commission
established in SB 459 which passed last
year is delayed and getting started with
its work
um but
you know I think hopefully that
commission will have some
recommendations the other thing is I I
didn't I didn't learn until the hearing
on this that RSA 627 6 Roman 8 already
permits authorized
um employees at a hospital or any health
care facility to use non-deadly Force
um when it's needed when they reasonably
believe it necessary to maintain the
decorum or safety and allows them even
to use deadly force
um when they think that's necessary to
prevent death or serious bodily injury
so there's already a statutory provision
that would allow a hospital with someone
who's presenting A continuing threat
like you describe
um that is disrupting the decorum and
safety of that institution to remove
people
so I it's just another reason why
you don't have to do necessarily such a
broad sweep to cover that unruly drunk
person you're talking about that would
also take with the people who experience
serious mental illness
any other questions representative Muse
and just just a quick follow-up this the
statute that you mentioned again could
you one one more with the once more with
the RSA I can talk really fast RSA 627
colon six
Roman eight
thank you welcome
anyone else have any questions
I'd like to ask uh
most Hospital settings
you don't move into training now we're
talking medical doctors we're talking uh
RNs
we're also talking uh
Advanced practitioners
these people all have a good working
knowledge and understanding of mental
health in general to be licensed don't
they well
I'm outside of my Lane a little bit here
I I think they have a license that in
their specialty areas of practice I
don't know what training that they
receive in terms of being able to
address someone with significant Mental
Health
active psychosis and and that may be one
of the reasons that the hospitals joined
in this in intervening in that lawsuit
and federal court
um where they argued successfully that
the state's failure to get these folks
out as soon as they're deemed
appropriate to be IE Aid is a you know
kind of is a taking for them and I think
what they argued is that they are not
prepared and adequately staffed and
compensated to deal with these
situations you know I our office isn't
part of that lawsuit but I've read the
decision and I've read some of the
pleadings and that's my understanding
that the hospitals are saying that
they're not fully equipped to and I you
know I would hope that they would be but
apparently they feel that they're not
necessarily fully equipped and
and helping people to get the training
they need it's maybe not something that
can be legislated it may be something
that is more important some places than
others it may be that some areas of the
state have the workforce that has the
necessary training and support available
to it to be able to address people in
such distress but others don't
it would be an issue for the commission
to take up
representative thank you I just wanted
to comment
um I was a nurse in a former life and
worked primarily in mental health uh
mostly pediatric mental health and child
protection and um I will say you know my
you know I've met lots of rotations in
nursing school went to BU and hospitals
that I've worked in and in an emergency
room you've got uh respiratory
therapists lab people people from X-ray
and I would be willing to to suggest
that most of those people do not have a
background
um in in mental mental health
um and you know it's you know I often
say you know I would be a great I was a
great psych nurse but if you put me on a
Cardiology unit I would not be good I
mean it would not be good for the
patients because that wasn't my area of
expertise so we all come to to the
healthcare
facilities with different backgrounds
and knowledge and you know one of the
other things that I that you know I'm
looking over the the um
input that we've received from
stakeholders I know as a nurse staffing
is often an issue in hospitals and you
know we we do a lot we cover a lot we we
do whatever we can but one of the
dangers I see in
um making
um first of all I think this this is in
the wrong statute to begin with I'm
confused by that but
um
when when the expectation is um when
when when security staff is short
um and there's a need to deal with a
situation the expectation now would
become would be placed upon Healthcare
Providers to deal specifically
um with these things I've been a little
concerned that that burden might in an
effort to help health providers
we might actually be burdening Health
Providers and putting them in some
situations where they're not adequately
prepared to to deal and so I don't know
I just
for me I you know I I um
with all the work that went into the
this um the commission
um and the stakeholder input
you know I I don't know I think that
first uh Cindy rosenwald's amendment was
the right way to go
um and I I think this Senate amendment
that was not vetted by anybody has just
sort of snowballed and you know both are
well-intentioned but I think the second
one has created more problems than than
was original so I would just like to see
us
look at that first the original
SB 85 excuse me 58
and you know see what their what is it
there that's problematic
um and is there something that we need
to change on that but I don't know I
just I think this is sort of it's just
convoluted and it's become a bigger
problem with this this floor Amendment
um and you know when all of the
stakeholders had come to agreement
in the beginning you know on the on um
the bill is introduced I know I'd sort
of like we're
we're in a you know I I don't know I
think it's it's more work that's sort of
non-productive because I think it's
already been hashed out and people have
come to an agreement so I don't know
just like just just to clarify you're
referring to the one dated March 29th
yes yeah and that's one of the things
that we looked at as a committee as well
as these are two separate uh really the
Senate Bill 58 is under two separate
statutes one's under the use of four
statue and the other one's under the
arrest statute the arrest statute to me
seems very clear and concise and that
still maintains the probable cause
standard for a warrantless arrest if we
go into the one under the use of force
that gets where a lot of people I think
lose it and get convoluted with the
language if that's just my personal take
and I've heard that from other members
of this committee as well I agree with
you and that use of force was really
intended for situations where you know
like a merchant a movie theater operator
we're not talking you know who's being
ripped off not by someone who's in a
psychiatric crisis and also in a
situation where they haven't registered
they don't have a band on them
identifying who they are they're fleeing
with their property and there's just not
a likelihood that they'll be able to
apprehend that person but to be
perfectly clear
this is just not about everybody who's
in a serious mental health crisis this
I've spoken with the director of
security for Dartmouth who's the former
Chief of Lebanon yesterday I spoke with
the sheriff of Sullivan County and the
local chief of police in Claremont which
has Valley Regional hospital and they're
all concise that this is an issue that
happens in their hospitals quite
regularly and they would be very in
support of having warrantless arrests
for assaults on on medical staff in
their facilities that they oversee I
think it depends on I mean we heard
various situations at the hearing some
involving staff on staff assault
which
I don't I don't to me that's a
management issue not a warrantless
arrest issue I mean that's that's a deep
problem when that kind of don't play
silence though it's where it is
workplace violence but that's where I
get to like what's the problem and are
we matching is this legislation a
solution to that problem what I mean to
me like when you can when you sort of
dissect what the committee heard
that horrific story we heard about the
surgeon who threw a blood-covered
instrument in the direction of a nurse
and when she went to complain about it
was told kind of like along what you
said representative Peru good thing you
ducked to me that is a huge management
problem that that management didn't have
her back how do we legislate that how do
we how do we manage those employee
unemployee situations that should never
occur I'm not sure this is that right we
talked I think there was testimony about
situations with visitors who got
disruptive in the hallway and were you
know yelling at each other I don't know
if there was an assault I don't remember
everything exactly in that situation I
think that's where RSA 627 6 8 comes
into play which would authorize the
hospital to
forcibly remove that person who's doing
that so I think we have that situation
covered
this is also maybe why the study
committee needs to do its work so that
we can really get a we they can get a
full understanding of what all the
permutations are to this issue what are
all the what are all the factors that
are impeding Workforce safety for our
Healthcare Workforce and what's the most
appropriate way to address those
thank you thank you so much
would like to go first
or nobody wants to talk now everyone's
stuck I know
just please identify yourself
for the record Holly Stevens and the
director of public policy for Nami New
Hampshire I did testify at the hearing
and you know I just wanted to say that
everybody behind you was in agreement it
is still an agreement that
um Senate Bill 58 as an introduced is a
good solution to this um existing
problem and I think it would address
representative prue's concerns because
it does allow for a warrantless arrest
if somebody's interfering with with
medical procedures so I think it does
address the concerns of people who are
intoxicated and you know getting in the
face of staff and not cooperating
because that is interfering with medical
problems excuse me the medical treatment
and you know Nami New Hampshire has
heard that people who are there on ieas
are being arrested or being brought to
jail so we do know that that is
happening in addition to all the other
situations that we've heard about but it
does happen
um
and the other thing that I just wanted
to bring up I spoke with our executive
director Susan Stearns at length about
this bill and if the committee is
looking at going with the broader
detainment
language we would ask that there be a
provision
um an amendment made that the hospitals
would have to keep track of everybody
who was arrested what their presenting
problem was whether they were on an iea
or not and that that information would
be provided publicly so that we would
have a sense of what was going on with
that the Senate Bill 58 language as
introduced were not as concerned about
so we wouldn't you know be looking at
any kind of reporting requirements but
if it's the broader language we would
ask that the committee consider
reporting requirements
thank you thank you any questions
thank you
thank you again for allowing us to speak
um so a couple things were stated
um by Ms Rosenberger that I wanted to
clarify so the workplace violence
prevention program I think my testimony
indicated this but I know you guys have
a lot of bills so Senate Bill 459 was
passed last year signed into law by the
governor he had a signing ceremony
that's how important it was at frisbee
Memorial Hospital at Senator Gray's
hospital because of the importance of
this
um that is in 15153 workplace violence
prevention program it outlines very
clearly what the hospital's required and
hospitals and Urgent Care centers are
responsible for and they are responsible
for doing
um training de-escalation
et cetera et cetera so I just want that
off to kind of just clarify that they
already do this anyway but now it's
documented in in the statute the
commission is a separate statute and
that is under
151j the New Hampshire Health Care
workplace safety commission again there
are two there are four sections of 459
three past one did not and that's why
we're here to talk about 58. so the
workplace safety commission is not a
study committee as was indicated this is
a long this is a permanent if you will
not permanent nothing's permanent but
this is a commission that will be
ongoing and not legislators involved
there are every single hospital has a
seat on it and every single Urgent Care
Center has the opportunity to have a
seat on it as well as the department of
HHS labor has a seat on it the Attorney
General's office has a seat on it New
Hampshire hospital has a seat on it
because they are not licensed the way
the other hospitals are
um and I and three members at large and
for instance we would like to have like
a nurse from The Nurses Association
appointed um for instance um to that
works in a hospital or or just um we
that's what we have requested the
commission all of this was delayed for a
very valid reason and this was all
negotiated last year in the house
finance when it was in house finance
it's moved to July of 23 for a good
reason um the department of HHS which is
where this Falls needs an appropriation
needs a staff because they the
commissioner would be responsible for
rulemaking to get the um the terminology
correct on the form that will be needed
to for every single Facility by law that
would have to fill out every single
assault you have to fill out a universal
form and because one of the reasons that
came out of the study committee was we
don't have consistent accurate data and
we want that for the commission which
will be protected by privacy just like
the quality commission is which is also
a permanent Commission
um they would be protected and have a
discussion about best practices
um what what the situations were ex and
then maybe come come back to the
legislature and ask for further changes
or just develop
um protocols working with law
enforcement working with um with the
Department with whoever um is
appropriate with the Attorney General's
office
um and the department so that is those
are very important components that are
already in law
um there so I just wanted to clarify
that
um so and then
I guess it was stated
um by um Ms Stevens and I appreciate
that
um Senate Bill 58 was negotiated by all
stakeholders I'm not quite sure where
the DRC stands now I I heard a lot um
from her and I'm not I I thought that
they were fine with Senate Bill 58 as
um introduced but um that was my
understanding and they did not testify
during the Senate phase the difference
again is what has changed because of the
floor Amendment but Senate Bill 58 and
we and I agree with representative
Murphy we call it the Rosenwald
Amendment the amendment that was
introduced and did not pass on the floor
makes a minor change to the way 58 was
introduced to clarify because one of the
concerns was we didn't want and I've
talked with some of you about this we
don't want law enforcement having to
make the determination of medical
necessity that is not that was never our
intent so to move the medical the
determination to be medically necessary
to the end of the sentence that's where
that's the Rosenwald Amendment which is
1251s which I know is in your docket um
for this bill
so we I mean we we agree we we did have
an agreement
um the problem is it did not pass the
Senate um but
if you believe this is the more
appropriate approach I continue to work
with I keep I keep Senator I talked to
Senator gray last night about this he's
very everyone's very interested in this
um as you know it it made the union
leader yesterday so
um I've talked I talked to Senator
Whitley last night I talked to another
Senator um they all care about this bill
um we will work whatever you pass if it
passes the house we will work to get and
I know you will help me
um get this through the Senate if it's
if it means 58 the Rosenwald Amendment
if that makes more more sense which
again you have stakeholders behind you
saying that that would work I think you
guys are the professionals you you've
been in this in this field um if you
believe this would work law enforcement
uh believes this would work they can't
speak on this bill because they don't
have Universal agreement but um I think
you will you've talked to um some law
enforcement they believe that this could
work
um
just wanted to help clarify a couple
things
representative
thank you thank you for taking my
question sure uh my question is about
the health care provider or his agent uh
section three
are we looking at the bill as amended
yes we don't have a copy of the original
Senate Bill we only have the amended
version of it so when you when people
are speaking okay we don't have that
copy so uh
that part there doesn't specific it
talks about agents which would come a
security office right because exactly
one thing that's on my mind is are there
scenarios in your experience or a
testimony that you've heard that there
are health care providers that do not
have security
um good question
um I think
um Mr Patty referenced some Hospital
small hospitals contract security
they're not as large as CMC so they
don't have Personnel on staff so they
contract with them unfortunately I don't
know that they I'd have to survey the
hospitals but I don't believe that
they're um there 24 7.
um so
they have security
um I just worry that they don't have
full-time security
oh hello all right so I guess my
question is uh let's say it's a
one of those smaller providers doctor's
office because this says healthcare
provider that would cover it yeah I
wanted to clarify that too I think
certain care things like that it's only
and not doctor's offices this does not
this statute um does not would not
um
well so specifically well the RSA
151.2 would I guess identify which ones
would be covered right that also cover
urgent care facilities uh 151 to yes I
believe it does
um but not doctors offices they're not
licensed under Health Facilities doctors
are licensed under as their clinicians
but their offices are not so offices
would not be um or um this would just be
I have to pull up the statute and I
should know it by heart but um it does
include urgent care in hospitals and ASC
Ambulatory Surgery centers what I'm
trying to get out here is
what protection do we provide to Health
Care Facilities covered under that
statute that don't have security where
they may have
uh healthcare providers that use
physical Force to detain somebody and
then no longer
protected under this statute if we
remove that part of the bill
so I'm what I'm asking you should we
still include that justification for
Force for health care providers nurses
doctors orderlies I don't even know if
that's a term that we use anymore and
not just security guards
I think I need John up here okay
and I know I asked John earlier I just
didn't know if um
we should also keep that part of the
language for that reason
what is here
I think he's talking about the use of
force
which is
where is that
that's under 627 627 thank you let me
pull it up
so earlier I asked you about
um and you didn't see a need for that to
be in there if you're already Justified
under the
law that passed a few years ago but my
concern is as if there are no security
on staff a smaller place
should we still allow justification to
protect health care providers that may
use physical Force to defend themselves
or to detain somebody
so yes in my opinion yes oh thank you
um
two different matters right so
you know the the
RSA under 627 6 Roman numeral eight is
not
is not just for
assaults that occur right sometimes
security has to escort patients you know
back to areas right and you know we
didn't have any protection you know
you know statutorily to be you know
physically grabbing people and and you
know bringing them back to to a room so
that was that intention of that
um but to your point yes you know as I
said before everybody has the right to
protect themselves you know and this
just clarifies it for me so yes uh short
answer I would say yes thank you
good
representative wheeler
um so you support SB 58 the Rosenwald
Amendment or as amended by the Senate
Rosenwald is what we agreed to last year
as part of you know SB 459 just clarify
that's the one dated to the 29th of
March
so yes yes
okay I have a copy if anyone needs
I do if actually can I get a connection
um can I get a follow-up ask also
um
can I can I just augment a little bit
sure we we are not opposed to 58 as
amended um by the Senate we could live
with it um but we are not it is not what
we all agreed to so
um if it again it is so important that
our health care workers be protected we
need something to pass I know that is
not a universal um position
um and you have heard testimony
um
not supporting the amended bill
we think 58 as the with the Rosenwald
amendment to clarify that works better
um but it did not pass the Senate so
that was our concern
um but this is a new body um this is a
new opportunity to to get it right and
then whatever changes then we would work
to get it through
um to the Senate but we all worked very
hard on Senate Bill 58 as introduced
and a question for you I I've been
hearing a couple of different things I
think the representative from the DRC
mentioned I know representative Muse
wrote down the the RSA number I didn't
have it
um it started with six but it's allowed
from her's testimony it allowed you to
use uh physical force or even deadly
force if necessary to restrain a patient
and that by her testimony was already in
statute
um so I'm a little bit confused by it
don't I mean I'm seeing that you already
have that power base done the testimony
from the DRC sure so
um
different scenarios right so yes we have
the right to detain somebody but we
don't have the power to arrest right
we're looking for the police
to come in when I call the police I want
them to be able to come in and make that
determination and be able to arrest that
patient without without applying for a
warrant under a misdemeanor level
offense
two different matters so if someone was
detained
and the police came you're saying that
they would let that person go or not get
a warrant to arrest them if that person
was detained for for using physical
violence against the health care worker
they may they have that discretion they
don't you know this isn't a mandatory
arrest we're not asking for that so the
police have the discretion to make that
determination at that point whether or
not they're going to arrest that person
a lot of time if I could just continue a
lot of times they don't make a decision
to arrest because
you know part of one of the limited
exceptions under the under 594 10 says
that the person will you know continue
that behavior or act out again right and
as I testified to before I don't
I don't understand putting a victim
in a position where they have to be
assaulted again
to um give the police the justification
to arrest
no further questions
representative
do we know why the Senate didn't like
the Rosenwald and they decided to go
with this was there something in this
that they said oh we don't like that and
we need this instead
um so I'm kind of trying to figure that
out so we could maybe speak to some of
it sure maybe smooth that over for them
and give them a version of this that is
tolerable yep
um
some of this happened behind the scenes
without our knowledge so um we know that
there were concerns
um it went to Senate Judiciary we know
that there were some concerns relative
to again the determination of a service
being medically necessary we worked on
that language again with stakeholders it
was important that it be in there to
ensure that we were talking about
services that were being medically that
were being provided that are medically
necessary to
kind of to limit yeah we wanted to be
very limiting as far as the application
of this and I think one example could be
if you are have been IE8 and you are
waiting for a transfer to a drf or New
Hampshire hospital you may not actually
be getting medically necessary Services
um because you have already been
determined that you need to be
transferred and you just wait you're
unfortunately you're boarding in the
hospital that's why we believed that it
was very important to include that some
Senators had a little bit of
um
heartburn with that that's why we moved
the language to the end of the sentence
because
um 58th
hold on as introduced
no as introduced I'm sorry hold on I
have it
um
I have a very big file uh let's see
um oh yeah
um the as introduced
um was while in the care of a medical
professional on the premises of a
residential care or Health Care Facility
as defined in 151.2
through actual or threatened violence
interfere with the provision of
medically necessary services so what we
did the Rosenwald Amendment just um
takes interferes with the provision of
health care services and then we moved
it to that a licensed Medical
Professional has determined to be
medically necessary some of the
arguments by some of the Senators was it
would be law enforcement's determination
that it was medically necessary and
we're like no that's not what that means
um because it would be in the medical
record if it went they were kind of
jumping to if it goes to if they press
charges and go to court we were just
talking about actually as John has um
stated just getting getting law
enforcement to act um and without a
warrant so that was that's the piece
that we were trying to focus on so we
thought well we'll make it really clear
um
so
we were there and then but we it still
wasn't not everyone was comfortable
um and then this floor amendment was um
so we did the the vote in the Senate was
delayed a number of times to try to get
to a place that um folks could be
comfortable with and that's where the
floor Amendment came in and again not
everyone saw it and not everyone is
ultimately comfortable with it
um it was a creative approach
um it just we're not sure that it it
hits the Mark
um the way that we were that we thought
58 would but it did the Rosenwald
Amendment failed by one vote or two
votes um I should say two because it
would have been even
um and um Senator Gannon was missing at
the time so it was um it was an 11 to 12
vote
um so a 12-12 would have failed of
course but um it failed by two boats so
it's not insurmountable I guess it's my
like a huge we're all against this no no
no not at all not at all
foreign
any other questions
just just did want to say
um just reading the uh the Senate report
from the original public hearing it it
looked like one of the Senators had a
question around whether or not
um the original bill would apply to
places like cafeterias and I thought
that by I thought that perhaps it needed
to be a little bit broader which may
explain the floor Amendment which is
much broader
um uh and and I think the where we have
the difference of opinion is whether or
not the bill should really be structured
around
um
situations where Medical Services aren't
being provided because of disruption
um or if
or if something is needed that basically
would apply everywhere in the entire
facility which it seems like New
Hampshire law already would cover it
would and I'll let John touch upon that
but that would be considered trespassing
if you're in the in the cafeteria and
you're just start throwing things
because you're frustrated because your
loved one is in the hospital and and for
whatever that you're a guest in that
private facility you could be escorted
out um so we don't and and it was
intentional to be very limiting
um as has been stated
um so
we don't want it to apply across the
across the institution
yeah I would agree she she hit on it
there's New Hampshire statutes are
really most of them are crafted very
well
um and you know we have not we I'm not
police anymore police have the power to
remove that type of person from a
cafeteria if you will I don't need to go
into all the details but yes she's right
thank you
any other questions for anyone
oh goodness
it's not really a question but I want to
have your input as a as I talk about
this so there's three separate things
going on here I know it was confusion
about why it was in physical Force
um and we talked about the amendment of
the law from the last couple years ago
that gave you guys permission to use
deadly force or non-deadly Force
um the three things going on here are
detaining somebody
using physical force and then a
warrantless arrest
so I think the
Rosenwald Amendment doesn't talk about
detaining somebody or giving anyone the
authority to detain
the
Amendment SB 58 as amended talks about
detainment and use of physical Force
also covers warrantless arrests but
probably not as as good as a rules and
wall Amendment does I don't have the
original copy as I said so
depending on which one we go with some
of them are missing some elements
some of them don't allow for detainment
by Hospital personnel
some of them don't allow for
justification of physical Force by
Hospital Personnel
um I actually I think this
floor Amendment only covers warrantless
arrests by officers so we're missing two
other elements there that I think may be
important still
in the bill
so great point Thank you so ultimately I
think Paula already alluded to this it
was
the amended the floor amendment was a
creative approach because there were
some concerns with the language in the
original sb58
as far as the detaining portion and the
physical Force portion you know elements
of that they're not needed in this
statute there there's
other statutory protections out there
ultimately you know no matter where we
want to hide this it is about a
warrantless arrest that's all this comes
down to is giving and it's not even
it's not even additional
a warrantless arrest Powers it's just
clarifying A circumstance in which the
police can do it so that was the
intention of the limited scope of the
original language right we didn't want
it to be
too broad you know to to concern others
um so you're right you're you're spot on
that language is is not necessary
thank you
thank you thank you you can keep it I
got extra copies
thank you I'll be really brief this is
Karen Rosenberg again policy director
disability rights Center I want to clear
up ambiguity because apparently I did
was not clear the language and the
Rosenwald amendment is acceptable to the
disability rights Center we it's very
close to what we had um all worked on
together and the bill is introduced and
we were consulted prior to the moving of
the languages Ms minnehan described to
you so just so that you all know we are
fine with that language and
um I thank my colleague Ms minnehan for
pointing out the difference between what
passed and what didn't pass and what's
in effect and not in effect right now
and moving forward I do want to point
out that the commission that was created
that's now in 151 J2 that hasn't been
able to start its work yet will be also
looking at supporting the development
and implementation of Healthcare
workflow Place violence prevention
programs including training so that is
in there so I know that hospitals are
working to do this but there's also more
work to be done so I wanted to clarify
that and
really all I wanted to say thank you for
the clarification thank you
anyone else have anything they want to
add to this discussion
I take it no one here is from motion
picture and theater orders for this bill
what we're going to do is we're going to
take a recess and come back at 11 40.
we are back in session
I want to recognize representative Muse
for a motion
thank you Mr chair I am uh
um
proposing
uh Amendment 2023-1498.
to SB 58 second
okay
I think Mr Peru got that one beat off
that I won yeah
so representative Muse could we get a
roll call
sure did you want me to uh
um explain I'm sorry yeah trying to get
ahead of myself here that's okay
representative go ahead and explain
what the amendment does I I think we you
know we want to say uh we heard you
um there were some definite concerns
with the bill the way that it came back
uh amended from the Senate and one of
the things that we realize is that
sometimes uh our process uh both in the
house and the Senate doesn't necessarily
always allow for the the degree of of
public input on uh on some of the things
that we do that we would like to speak
especially when it comes to floor
amendments
so in effect today we had a we had a
public hearing the public hearing that
we we didn't have uh on on the bill as
it came through from the Senate
so I I want to thank everybody who came
out today uh I think this has helped us
get to a better place
um in anticipating uh based on the
public hearing where this might go I had
prepared an amendment in advance and and
it looks like this is where we've wound
up what what the amendment uh
effectively does is take us back to the
original bill
um as it was submitted uh and
incorporates the Rosenwald Amendment
and uh I we we uh believe that uh this
will address the concerns of the the
medical community uh it will provide
police with the power to make a
warrantless arrest uh in these
situations
um uh hopefully our medical personnel
across the state will feel uh a bit
safer in these situations I think we
realize that there's a lot of other
stuff that needs to be done in terms of
things like
housing mental health people people with
mental health issues in emergency rooms
and and there were I think
increasing the safety of our hospitals
is an ongoing work in progress but I
think this bill could be an important
part of the picture
um so uh I'm happy to introduce this and
uh and uh and I hope we can make a
recommendation to the full committee to
pass the bill with this amendment
thank you representative pru would you
like to add anything to your second
uh
we were kind of along the same lines and
presented to beat us to the punch and uh
I'm glad he did because I didn't have to
go get the amendment so pretty happy
about that but this is and like you said
we heard what you were saying and we
kind of agree that
this is much cleaner much neater and
exactly what you guys all agreed to so
we're glad to push this forward
give me a second a second
representative wheeler
she was robbed in the second no
um you know I think that this is
absolutely the appropriate solution I
think it's been here sort of all along
um I thank representative Muse for
um going ahead and getting this
amendment made I stakeholders are in
agreement I think those of us who have a
sense of how hospitals work and
um you know we want we want to do
something for health providers because
we know it's a it's an issue but we also
want law enforcement to be able to use
discretion and to take action when they
need to and and I think this certainly
allows that to happen and I'm sure down
the road there will be gaps or holes
that will need to be addressed but those
things can can happen but at least
there's something
immediate and and I'm happy to support
this
representative Willow well I just want
to add on to what's the great things
that have been said and totally agree
I'm thank everyone for coming out today
uh this is clearly an important thing
that my grandmother is a nurse and I
know very clearly that there are
situations happening in the hospitals
that need to be addressed and I'm happy
to come together on a bipartisan
amendment to address those
um I did just want to weigh those
concerns very carefully with the what
was brought up by the DRC and Nami which
are completely valid concerns of not
wanting to criminalize mental health
further than we already have in our
society and I think hopefully this opens
up a conversation about uh not waving
our magic wand but starting to slow and
arduous process that is the sausage
making to get robust community-based
services so we can hopefully avoid in a
preventative way this problem without
further criminalizing people but I'm
happy to move forward in support of this
amendment because I know as uh grandson
of a stakeholder how important this is
for
our nurses and our health care workers
in our hospitals so I'm very happy to
move forward with this so I'm glad we've
made that distinction I'm no
representative proves about it what's up
she's gonna be so proud she already is
anyone else
I like to say that we recognize the
importance of this issue and the
bipartisan support hopefully will
continue in our full committee and then
on the house floor I think this is uh
probably overdue and
it's time that the criminal justice
committee hopefully will start taking a
more proactive response to some of these
issues been coming before us I know
we've had some people been very upset
about the retention of all our bail and
judicial bills that we've been holding
but this one I'm very comfortable should
move smoothly through our full committee
at this point and I'd like to thank you
all for giving up some time this morning
to come out and join us
with that go ahead and we need to vote
and do the Roll Call
did you want me to make the motion
no your big motions of Google well the
motion is we're voting on you know
roll call on the uh on on the motion
not to pass
second and I will I guess I should uh
um never having been a never having
clerked here
we go hi representative Murphy yes
representative Prue yeah
representative moose yes representative
Manion yes representative tensar yes and
the chair is a yes
we are six to nothing unanimous
thank you all
thank you oh no thank you and with that
uh Senate Bill 58 is now closed